ailleurs annoncé vouloir anticiper sa
montée au capital de votre groupe pour
mois de février de cette année ce qui
lui permettrait notamment de prendre le
contrôle des titres de presse dans ce
contexte nous avons souhaité vous
entendre pour nous exposer votre
sentiment comme actionnaire d'un grand
groupe des médias sur les conséquences
d'une concentration forte qui pourrait
d'ailleurs être renforcée encore dans
les toutes prochaines semaines mais
également sur les relations que vous
pouvez entretenir avec les rédactions
des médias de votre groupe nous essayons
en effet déterminer le rôle joué par
l'actionnaire dans la conduite au
quotidien du travail journalistique et
en particulier dans la production de
l'information je vous propose comme nous
le faisons à chacune des éditions de
vous laisser la parole pendant dix
minutes pour un propos introductif et
puis bien sûr nous enchaînons nous
continuerons par la suite à vous poser
des questions le rapporteur commencera
une première série de questions et les
sénateurs présents physiquement ou
derrière leur écran pourront également
vous poser les questions je vous précise
que cette hausse usions c'est d'audition
pardon est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du sénat et qu'elle fera
également l'objet d'un compte rendu qui
sera publié enfin je rappelle pour la
forme qu'a faux témoignage devant une
autre commission denquête seraient
passibles des peines prévues aux
articles 413 tirer ne pas dans 400 34-13
400 ans 34-14 et 15 du code pénal je
vous précise également qu'il vous
appartient le cas échéant d'indiquer vos
éventuels liens d'intérêts ou conflits
d'intérêts en relation avec l'objet de
la commission denquête je vais vous
invitez maintenant mais chez lagardère a
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure je vous
remercie et donc je vous donne la parole
pour dix minutes
le rouge voilà parfaitement ok très bien
m'écouter je vais utiliser cette ce
temps de d'introduction mais avant je
voudrais juste corrigé peut-être si je
puis me permettre bien sûr je suis allée
mots dont l'un portant sur tout un
groupe d'édition comme le nôtre il n'y a
pas de rapprochement éditoriale avec le
groupe yves inde il ya un rapprochement
industriel et économique mais je pense
qu'on va en parler tout à l'heure donc
quand même d'entrer le le corriger parce
que je je sais que dans des bouches plus
malveillantes ça peut être interprété de
manière différente alors je vais
utiliser ce moment d'introduction si
vous le permettez pour vous
expliquer les raisons pour lesquelles ce
groupe est le groupe qu'il est
aujourd'hui tant du point de vue
actionnariale que du point de vue du
périmètre de ses activités je vais
commencer par par la
com comme vous le savez ce groupe est né
dans la haute technologie puis il a une
branche média importante dans l'année
1980 81 par l'acquisition du groupe
hachette c'était donc un conglomérat et
dès le début des années 2000 nous avons
fait le constat et quand je dis nous je
me permets de le dire parce que j'ai
maintenant soixante années de maison
lagardère donc je connais un petit peu
tout le monde et notamment bien
évidemment jean luc lagardère nous en
avons conclu que ce conglomérat ne
pouvait pas continuer à se développer de
cette manière parce que nous n'aurions
plus des moyens à la fois économique et
financier de nous développer dans toutes
nos branches il y avait donc une
décision à prendre qui n'était pas une
décision facile qui a fait dire là
encore assez même
boucher et plumes bienveillante que le
groupe s'était rétrécie en réalité c'est
une stratégie délibérée est totalement
assumée et j'ai fait le choix à ce
moment là au décès de jean luc lagardère
de privilégier deux branches parce que
je me suis aperçu j'ai pensé qu'à
l'époque ces deux branches pouvaient
avoir un rôle mondial et qu'on pourrait
arriver au podium des leaders mondiaux
ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui alors il
ya évidemment comme toujours beaucoup de
chance il ya évidemment du talent de nos
équipes mais à l'époque c'était pas
évident parce que ce que nous on appelle
le travel retail c'est à dire donc ses
magasins dans les transports de gares et
aéroports
représenté pratiquement rien du tout du
groupe c'était très très peu de choses
et le groupe d'édition hachette de
l'époque étaient certains groupes
flamboyant parce qu'avec des marques
extrêmement symbolique en france mais
c'était un groupe franco français qui
venait d'ailleurs de passer d'une
période dans me and et 90 difficile où
on a eu des pertes par moments et puis à
ce moment là on pensait un peu ce qu'on
a pensé de la musique après c'est à dire
c'est vraiment des métiers du passé vous
allez être en plus en 2000 ou souvenirs
on était en plein dans la bulle internet
on disait mais mon dieu que vont-ils
faire dans l'écrit et dans le papier
donc c'était un pari qui n'était pas
évident et moi j'étais persuadé comme
ceux qui sont restés en la musique
d'ailleurs que c'était au contraire un
métier qui allait perdurer et qui ne
serait pas en concurrence avec les
formats numériques la démonstration en a
été faite alors c'est plus facile de le
dire maintenant qu'avant bien évidemment
enfin bon on a eu quand même quand même
pas mal de chance et puis il ya eu un
environnement vous avez cité tout à
l'heure ou disons un ensemble de
d'activité que l'on a sanctuarisé pour
reprendre les mots de jean luc lagardère
c'est ce qu'ils souhaitaient d'ailleurs
et qui forme et de europe 1 paris match
et le journal du dimanche europe 1
d'ailleurs qui est entré dans le groupe
en 1974 donc bien bien bien avant que
l'on ait même l'idée d'entrer dans les
médias parce que ça faisait partie des
activités de monsieur sylvain floirat
quitte avec il y avait aussi qu'ils
avaient aussi matra rebonds
et ce périmètre là
nous l'avons aujourd'hui et nous le rend
demain
quels que soient les résultats de
l'opéra en cours et cela me permet de
passer au deuxième point que je veux
traiter ici qui est le présent et
l'avenir actionnariale de notre groupe
je n'aurais jamais transformé la
commandite en société anonyme je
n'aurais jamais
sollicitée est accueilli avec
bienveillance le groupe vivendi en mars
je n'aurais jamais soutenu loupé à
amicale de vie 20 10 actuellement si je
n'avais pas été à la fois rassurée et
assuré que d'une part l'intégrité du
groupe serait conservé ses délires telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
que le management seraient conservés et
au delà du management plus important sa
stratégie sa stratégie de développement
et que l'entreprise resterait coté et je
dois le dire même si c'est pas tout à
fait le genre de choses que l'on entend
ce moment que je suis infiniment
reconnaissant
à la fois à monsieur vincent bolloré qui
est un ami depuis plus trente ans nos
familles se connaissent et se croisent
depuis plus de 30 ans
infiniment reconnaissants à sa famille à
elle c'est à dire à yannick bolloré quel
président du conseil de surveillance de
vivendi 1 cyril bolloré qui est le
président du groupe bolloré qui fait
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'était un hasard
de calendrier
ses 200 ans quelle réussite et je suis
français avant tout moi ça me fait
plaisir pour la france aussi et je suis
aussi reconnaissant au management de
viven dit que je peut côtoyer en ce
moment c'est à dire à la fois arnaud de
puyfontaine que je connais aussi depuis
une bonne trentaine d'années
président du directoire de vivendi et
maxime saada dont on ne peut pas dire
qu'il n'a pas contribué au redressement
de canal c'est important à l'écosystème
du cinéma français et de certains sports
français
tout ceci pour vous dire que
d'abord je suis pas du genre à donner un
coup de pied à quelqu'un qui m'a donné
un coup de main je signe que ça ne se
fait pas et entre familles encore - et
ensuite tout ceci pour vous dire que si
vous cherchez un interlocuteur
aujourd'hui et demain
à la fois pour la partie europe 1 jdd et
match où vous l'avez devant vous et vous
l'avez aussi avec constance benqué que
j'ai nommé à cette place si vous
cherchez un interlocuteur parce que je
crois que vous avez aussi interroger
auditionné des éditeurs
de notre parti éditions dont on est si
fier vous avez l'interlocuteur aussi en
face de vous et bien évidemment accès à
monsieur pierre leroy mon compagnon de
route qui était le compagnon de route de
jean luc lagardère avec qui j'ai quand
même passé
quarante bonnes années de vie commune et
nous sommes à votre disposition
donc certes le monde pour nous change
parce que nous sommes à dos et un groupe
puissant qui va nous aider et qui va
nous donner les moyens de notre ambition
mais d'un autre côté et c'était l'accord
de tous les actionnaires et de viven dit
en premier lieu
la gouvernance de groupe lagardère ne
change pas voilà j'ai posé un petit peu
là l'ailé comment dirais-je les pièces
de la discussion qu'on va avoir et je
suis évidemment ma disposition pour
répondre aux questions
merci vous avez effectivement
donné un certain nombre d'indications
sur lequel nous allons revenir dans un
instant et je pense que le premier qui
veut revenir ses deux rapporteurs du
reste david assouline
bonjour monsieur lagardère j'aurai
davantage c'est que vous avez mis les
pieds dans le plat de ce qui peut être
une discussion entre nous avec l'opéra
que vous qualifiée d'amicale
de monsieur bolloré mais avant pour être
avoir l'opinion d'un acteur essentiel
sur les vingt dernières années au moins
de la concentration dans les médias
notre thématique générale
j'ai besoin d'avoir votre point de vue
en arrière le été cet acteur et vous
avez
pratiqué toutes les concentrations sur
lesquels on travaillait
concentration horizontale
concentration diagonale
concentration verticale et au début il y
avait aussi ce que ce qui est parfois
aux discussions
sur la l'originalité entre guillemets
des concentrations aux français une
activité
important dans le domaine militaire donc
dépendants de la commande publique avec
la fabrication de missiles bon donc
on a l'impression que toutes ces
tentatives là et c'est c'est derrière
vous quelque part puisque maintenant on
est plus vous qui être le maître des
horloges des concentrations même si vous
restez vous l'avez dit un acteur et vous
dites c'est ça qu'on discutera tout à
l'heure un acteur qui est resté
complètement indépendant et kinés qui ne
passe pas en tous les couacs sous les
coupes idéologique ou
éditorial de quelqu'un d'autre donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous nous
dire quelles étaient les logiques
poursuivi par votre groupe
dans toutes ses aventures de
concentration très différentes et en
vous retournant
quel bilan tirez vous de ces tentatives
là et du moment où vous êtes arrivé
finalement à vous même accepté une au
pea d'un plus gros
dans vous parlez verticalité
d'horizontalité de diagonale j'avoue que
je suis probablement moins bons joueurs
d'échecs que vous
l'histoire du groupe en réalité elle et
elle et elle est simple et on dit
toujours une stratégie elle est faite
pour être appliquée quoi qu'il arrive la
réalité c'est que vous avez des fois des
événements qui interviennent que vous ne
maîtrisez pas qu'ils sont parfois des
opportunités que vous saisissez parce
que c'est le bon moment parce que vous
êtes en forme financièrement et puis
parce que ça fait sens dans votre
stratégie mais c'est peut-être parce que
vous aviez imaginé au départ et ça ça
arrive ça arrive souvent ce groupe comme
je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure il est
l'aîné de la haute technologie c'était
la première passons de de jean luc
lagardère
qui était adossé à l'époque un
capitaliste qui était monsieur sylvain
fois qui était l'actionnaire donc dès ce
que l'on appelait les engins matra de
matra et puis aussi d'europe 1
donc il n'y avait pas de volonté
particulière chez dans le groupe en tout
cas de se dire on va additionner avec
les anges à matra puisque je soupçonne
un peu votre question si je peux dire
est qu'un soupçon ça faisait beau oui
ils n'ont pas redonné le terme ça
faisait partie d'un tout en réalité et
donc c'est c'est comme ça que nous
sommes trouvés et que mon père s'est
trouvé à la tête donc de matra la haute
technologie et d'europe 1 et pour tout
vous dire
même si j'étais moins comment dirais-je
passionné par cette partie du groupe
j'en étais malgré tout extrêmement fier
on a toujours dans ce groupe était dans
des activités de souveraineté et ça
c'est une fierté que ce soit la haute
technologie
que ce soit l'édition que ce soit le
scolaire etc s'il peut y avoir un fil
directeur si vous vouliez trouver un fil
directeur de ce groupe ce serait
celui-là des activités qui sont
importantes importante certes
économiquement mais importante aussi
pour le pays
et il est arrivé en 1981 et là aussi
croyez le bien l'idée n'était pas
forcément de faire croître europe 1 mais
il est arrivé une opportunité
et cette opportunité ça a était hs qui
était une entreprise qui se portait mal
et qui nous a en fait été apportée par
un banquier monsieur jean-luc encore un
autre gendre y est jean luc lagardère
j'étais un petit peu jeune à l'époque
j'avais une vingtaine d'années en 1980 à
trouver une opportunité très belle
c'est difficile de faire plus patriotes
que jean luc lagardère et
pour lui être le propriétaire est
développée
des livres de l'éducation
ça l'à beaucoup intéressé beaucoup
fascine et donc non seulement ils
pouvaient faire une bonne affaire
économique mais en plus il restait dans
ses passions et c'est ça le fait
directeur sens absolument à aucun moment
se dire mon dieu est ce que tout ceci va
me profiter verticalement
horizontalement et cetera rebonds
alors quand on est un groupe indépendant
comme le nôtre la liberté c'est avant
tout sa capacité à gagner de l'argent
c'est peut-être triste mais mais c'est
comme ça et donc l'aspect économique et
financier était extrêmement important et
pourtant dieu sait que lui n'était pas
financier c'était un ingénieur à la base
et ils avaient des visions stratégiques
il en a réussi énormément il en arrive
en art et en arrêter d'autres bien
évidemment comme tout le monde mais dieu
sait que ça n'était pas un financier pur
jus mais il savait il comprenait que
c'était un passage obligé
et donc à partir de là nous allons nous
sommes retrouvés quand même à la tête
d'un conglomérat et je voulais dis en
toute sincérité
nous n'avions vraiment pas les moyens de
développer tout ça est la création d'
eads la création d' eads c'était déjà sa
sortie par le haut puisque nous n'étions
plus maîtres de notre destin que nous le
partageons avec l'état français ce qui
était évidemment quelque chose
extrêmement flatteur mais aussi avec
d'autres actionnaires nos amis allemands
de daimler à l'époque donc déjà à cette
époque on savait que ce groupe ne
pourrait pas résister aux immenses
besoins d'investissements que
nécessitait toutes ses activités et donc
petit à petit j'en reviens donc à ce que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on a dû
j'ai dû et ce qui m'a valu d'ailleurs
tous et toutes ses félicitations de
rétrécissement du groupe mais ça c'est
pas important je me suis dit ce groupe
ne survivra pas s'il est comme ça il
doit donc pour devenir plus grands
passer par une phase où il sera plus
petit et je me suis dit devant lui pas
ces derniers jours mais enfin disons
durant ces derniers mois
que franchement être le leader mondial
du livre par demander moi cette
expression ça a de la gueule et
évidemment il a adhéré à ces stratégies
parce que c'était sa passion et donc de
fil en aiguille après on a développé un
petit peu tout ça alors europe 1
qu'est-ce qu'on comment puis-je vous
lire repas il y était depuis 74 il a
digéré dirait diriger il a été dans les
dents dans ses bureaux le vendredi
j'allais me retrouver dans les bureaux
ouverts tout ça ça on est quand même
très très loin d'aider des vraies
ambitions économiques et financières
d'un groupe oui mais comme l'a dit très
justement un moment martin bouygues
lorsqu'il a voulu conserver bouygues
telecom il n'y a pas non plus que
l'argent il y à 7,7 petit comment
dirais-je
sentimentalité autour de cette maison
europa qui fait qu'on l'a tout de suite
sanctuariser jdd match nous est venu
daniel filipacchi après hachette et ça a
été la même chose et donc j'ai poursuivi
cette fidélité à l'héritage de 2 2 jean
luc lagardère si je puis me permettre
des gens déterminés pardonnez moi d'être
un peu long
on m'a posé quand je suis arrivé une
question
très sympathique sommes toujours en
disant mais qu est-ce que votre père
serait fier de tout ça finalement et
même en prenant l'hypothèse d'une opr
que j'espère réussi bientôt donc d'un
vivendi qui sera majoritaire au groupe
lagardère je peux vous le dire et vous
l'affirmez qu'un cela m'honore cela
honore le groupe et cela honore la
mémoire de jean luc lagardère parce que
ce qu'il voulait avant tout c'est que
ces activités là finissent par dominer
et nous n'avions pas le choix nous
n'avions pas d'autre choix
moi je ne verserai pas dans l'honneur
c'est juste jeu
je voulais avoir de votre part le
l'analyse rétrospective
de toutes les ambitions qu'il y a eu
dans le domaine médiatique
c'est pour cela que j'ai parlé de
différentes concentrations vous êtes un
acteur de la concentration
ce sont des définitions un petit peu
dans le jargon médiatique horizontale
ses camps dans la même dans le même
secteur par exemple les chaînes de télé
ou
multiplie les chaînes ou dans le domaine
de la radio
diagonale sait qu on a dans deux médias
sur trois radio télé presse
une activité et le vertical aujourd'hui
c'est tout ce qui vient
concentré y compris jusqu'à pour
certains des tuyaux même
dans toutes les chaînes la chaîne de la
valeur ou la distribution us que la
publicité les kiosques à 20 voilà donc
il ya il ya différentes formes de
concentration et je pense que vous avez
essayé effet un peu testé toutes ses
formes là et en se retournant
alors vous étiez opposition très forte
quel bilan vous tient et c'est à dire
c'est pas vous qui
absorbé l'indicé lui qu'est-ce qui elle
n'a pas marché qu'est ce qui
vous dit tout mon guide cellulite
financiers
je suis pas un mais ça n'en faites vous
du temps puisque deux nous ont dit que
c'étaient des mécènes
est-ce que du point de vue financier
c'est via peut-être peut-être ça la
question est ce que c'est le constat que
il a ses limites à cela est
vraiment à aucun moment vous pensez que
quand même
europe 1 paris match et tout c'est aussi
un prestige un moyen d' influence pas
seulement une espèce de
2,2
voilà de la tri ou de deux petits joyaux
c'est sympa de l'avoir il y a quand même
ses dents c'est dans ce domaine qu'il
n'est pas forcément le plus rentable qui
a eu les investissements il ya d'autres
activités économiques dans le pays où on
peut être tenté pas ce que c'est c'est
tout aussi nécessaire pour notre
industrie et notre nation pour son
prestige là le domaine médiatique qui
est là pour europe 1 et c'est assez peu
rentable c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire il n'y a jamais eu l'idée que c'est
une façon de peser
et et d'influencé jamais donc là deux
questions 1 japon de questions jamais et
jamais elles sont gérées dans un but
totalement différent et c'est pas parce
qu'on ne réussit pas dans ses objectifs
qu'on a d'autres objectifs en tête
vous à la raison au repas est dans une
situation difficile ça fait quatre cinq
ans c'est comme ça et on a besoin de
s'adosser à une chaîne toutes les radios
généralistes sont adossés à des chaînes
il y en a qui ont été créés comme tel
comme rmc il y en a qui ont l'ont été
parce qu'il ya eu des rapprochements m6
rtl par exemple le public il a été créé
aussi comme ça elles le sont toutes et
nous ça nous manque ça nous manque parce
que ça nous manque en terme de notoriété
ça nous manque en termes de synergies
éventuelles qu'on peut créer et on en a
besoin je ne reconnais absolument pas je
pensais en même temps que vous vous
exprimez monsieur le rapporteur mais je
prends je me balade de haut en bas de
droite à gauche et d'euros gauche et
dans les coins je ne nous vois pas avoir
dominé quelques concentration que ce
soit et je vais vous donner quelques
chiffres
par exemple quand on compare notre radio
publique
france inter à 660 émetteurs nous en
avons 330 alors c'est sûr puisqu'on
parle beaucoup de football en même temps
avec 22 joueurs moi je vous donne un
porte quelle équipe et ça ne retire
absolument rien au talent des équipes de
france inter absolument rien ça n'est
absolument pas à nos mines m mais quand
on parle de concentration elle est là la
concentration le budget de radio france
doit être aux alentours de 630 millions
celui de toutes les radios commerciales
et 330 je n'ose même pas vous dire quel
est celui de repas quand on parle de
part de marché publicitaire
et quand on fait la somme agrégé du
futur tf1 m6 et rtl que je crois
certains certaines comment dirais-je
autorités ont pratiquement déjà adoubée
on a 70 % du marché de la télévision et
à 50 % du marché de la radio europe 1
puis jdd plus match on est à 3 % 3 % où
est la concentration et vous pouvez y
ajouter tout ce que vous voulez pour
passer de 3 à 40 on peut y aller donc je
vous assure il n'ya et
en passant vous en pensez quoi de cette
concentration de l'avant je suis je suis
absolument pas si je suis absolument par
là pour pousser vous la juge a évoqué
ses mots non non non non c'est pas ça
mais je l'entends c'est sans jugement ce
que vous avez l'air de dire que 60% ce
sont des chiffres ce sont des chiffres
voilà ce que je fais c'est que je ne
juge pas le chiffre dans sa valeur
absolue parce que je pense que j'aurais
à le faire auprès de l'art comme bientôt
j'imagine ce que je vois ce que je
regarde c'est je compare des chiffres au
nôtre et je me dis que la concentration
elle est très honnêtement elle n'est pas
chez nous franchement elle n'est pas
chez nous donc c'est un mauvais procès
que qu'on nous fait je crois et c'est
dommage alors je le prends bien parce
que j'estime qu'on donne un petit plus à
la notoriété de nos marques et c'est
vrai on a une notoriété importante
donc si je compte dans le domaine de
l'édition s'est alors oui mais moi je
veux bien revenir c'est pour arriver au
chiffre non mais on va y revenir tout à
l'heure on va revenir tout à l'heure
enfin on apprend on a droit aussi d'être
compétent et dénis le meur mais bien sûr
mais c'est pas des reproches et je vous
dis mieux avant de venir comme ça on
accordait des questions concrètes
vous avez indiqué dans le figaro en juin
dernier qu'aucune radio n'avait le droit
d'être un média d'opinion wii est cocu
qu'aucun actionnaire particulier n'a de
droit particulier sur europe 1 oui
donc vous validez je confirme vous aviez
ajouté que dirk europe 1 pas sous la
coupe de vivendi c'est un fantasme qui
frôle le complotisme absolument vous
aller jusque là c'est du complotisme et
je le pense et le penser c'est du
complot tissot vous l'avais pensé jolie
dans l'introduction un truc avec
l'actualité depuis joueurs vous pensez
toujours c'était
qu'ils pouvaient qu'il n'y avait pas de
crainte à avoir là-dessus à tel point
que ça pouvait du complotisme parce que
les faits depuis c'est d un changement
intervenu sur la grille d'europe 1
depuis la rentrée 2001 terre alors même
que l'offre publique d'achat
mené pas leur with andy n'a pas encore
abouti tu en a témoigné
du contraire par exemple comment
expliquez vous un tel décalage donc
autres ses propos et la réalité
comment vous interprétez l'éviction
d'hervé gattegno de la tête de paris
match et du jdd
l'accélération annoncé de l'opéra prévu
initialement décembre est avancée en
février ne vient-elle pas confirmé une
prise de contrôle déjà prégnante de vie
lundi sur l'activité de votre groupe
quel rôle conservez-vous au son du
groupe si vous pouvez nous dire en gros
vous nous dit en préambule je vais
rester le maître je pas dit le maître à
jouer des plus modestes
vous avez dit que vous quand on voudra
savoir des choses sur europe 1 paris
match c'est vous l'interlocuteur vous
même sur achète édition c'est vous un
interlocuteur absolue dire que vous
assumez que en plus dans la même ligne
éditoriale c'est à dire dans une ligne
éditoriale qui ne peut pas être
confondue avec celle qu'un prix mis
lundi dans ces médias c'est ça que vous
nous affirmer hors
pourquoi des dizaines de journalistes
d'europe 1 qui tenait à leur maison qui
la faisait vivre dans son identité
depuis longtemps avec des grandes plumes
y compris des humoristes très populaire
ont dû partir considérant que ce qu'on
avait changé disons de deux projets
pourquoi des proches connu sur le plan y
compris idéologiques ont été nommés à la
tête du jdd c'était pas
oui le directeur il y en a eu le
directeur de la rédaction du jdd
qui est un chroniqueur quasi régulier
plusieurs fois par semaine sur ses news
ça c'est une nouveauté de 2,2 par
rapport à ce qui existait avant bon
paris match direction paris match
ressemble plus à a
à une mine éditorial en tous les cas ou
à un courant de pensée ou alors un une
filiation
qui n'était pas celle qui était imprimé
quand vous étiez vous le patron est pas
et pas monsieur bolloré donc on a même
on a même ça m'a été dit
monsieur
monsieur donna vidal revel avait prévenu
la rédaction dans des propos que un
journal a dévoilé vous êtes déjà
salariées de vincent bolloré dans les
faits alors que l'opéra n'était pas
encore
déclenché le le 11 mai 2021 il dit déjà
ça à la rédaction tous savent où me dit
non c'est pas vrai ils sont pas partis
pour ça
c'est la même ligne éditoriale c'est
comme avant c'est juste une opération de
protection quasiment financière par un
pas avec un grand géant qui est un ami
et c'est pour ces cccc pour des raisons
économiques c'est pour continuer à être
performant
c'est ça que vous nous dites ici vous
permet c'est pas uniquement pour
continuer de performance et pour grandir
c'est pour investir
davantage dans les métiers qui sont les
nôtres on s'est fait un peu rattrapé par
le cos vide il faut le reconnaître aussi
qui a mis une de nos deux jambes un peu
un peu un peu par terre bon c'est plutôt
bien redresser on a eu accès à un pg e
qu'on a tout de suite remboursée
d'ailleurs donc oui on était dans une
position qui était effectivement
délicate en plus on était vous souvenez
un peu assiégée par un activiste qui
était assez soutenu d'ailleurs par un
certain nombre de médias d'opinion pour
le coup qui aurait préféré évidemment à
découpage du groupe plutôt que ce groupe
reste reste intacte mais bon c'est pas
c'est pas le débat moi je veux bien vous
reprendre toutes les nominations qui ont
été faites et je vais le faire
d'ailleurs puisque vous méritez vous
aviez le temps donc c'est parfait je
n'ai juste qu'un petit déjeuner demain
matin donc on a tous notre temps
les unes après les autres monsieur
gattegno on m'a reproché de l'avoir
nommé pour des raisons politiques les
mêmes personnes
lorsqu'il est lorsque nous avons dans ce
qu'on s'est quitté évidemment ont changé
de stratégie et on vit là la main de fer
monsieur vincent bolloré par exemple
l'idée c'était que moi j'avais essayé ça
c'était mon idée de vous mettre une
personne en commun à la fois sur le jdd
sur match c'était pas pour faire des
économies sur les gens c'était juste que
je pensais que ça allait être beaucoup
plus efficace et que je pensais que
certains journalistes de match pourrait
aider au jdd et inversement des
correspondants alex trangé que c'est à
ça pourrait faire dd des ajouts
bénéfique bon voila
j'ai estimé que ceux ci n'allait pas au
bout et puis à peut-être eu d'autres
raisons sur lesquelles monsieur gâtés
lyon et moi même n'avons pas souhaité
communiquer et je le respecte par contre
moi ce que je peux vous dire et je suis
quand même sous serment ça n'est pas
rien que monsieur gattegno et moi même
nous ne sommes pas quittés pour des
raisons éditoriales
on peut pas dire tout et son contraire
on me dit maintenant monsieur béglais
mais ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même un peu fort de café vous dites
monsieur béglé et chroniqueur d'une
émission menée d'ailleurs passe par
pascal praud et pour vous provoquer
encore davantage émission d'ailleurs que
j'aime beaucoup l'émission et pascal
praud mais vous oubliez de dire que
c'est le patron du point et là ça pose
pas de problème il est patron du
printemps mais ça on le met de côté mais
alors attention il est chroniqueur de
ces news ça c'est horrible et maintenant
qu'il est chez nous c'est la même
personne
monsieur béglé je le connais depuis très
longtemps et pour tout vous dire j'ai
failli même le prendre quand j'ai choisi
monsieur hervé gattegno
j'ai hésité un peu et puis finalement
j'ai pris avec gatineau parce qu'il ya
un moment il faut faire des choix mais
je l'aurait volontiers pris bon
ensuite vous me parlez du jdd pendant en
gros ce que marc druz dit puisque ce que
ce que vous me disent que ce que je
comprends c'est qu'en fait ça n'est pas
un un changement
autres vos propres
[Musique]
id ou contre vos pas du tout c'est une
rencontre en fait vous êtes d'accord
vous adorez l'émission de pascal praud
oui là et donc ça vous est pas imposée
vous adhérer complètement c'est ça que
vous dites mais c'est plus que j'adhère
puisque je voulais le prendre à une
époque où oublie lundi n'était même pas
à notre capitale donc c'est pas cela
n'est pas sorti du chapeau ce jour là
vous me parlez après du de match et
pourquoi les journalistes de repas que
vous avez admiré que qui ont fait la
maison repeint les patrick cohen etc des
grandes plumes pourquoi ont-ils jugé
linverse par dizaines ils sont partis
qu'à ce que qu'elle est
l'incompréhension vous dit exactement
l'inversé et
on en a on a bien envie de
comment vous pouvez l'affirmé comme ça
si on me répond sûr pourquoi ils sont
partis je l'appelle monsieur quand tout
a été
remercié mais je vais vous le dire je la
firme parce que je sais ce que je pense
et quand je décide quelque chose je sais
quels sont les éléments que je mets en
face je ne peux pas empêcher des gens de
ta être de mon avis est de penser qu'il
ya quelque chose d'autre ça n'est pas le
cas mais je n'y peux rien et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle les
clauses de cession les clauses le
consciente son sont parfois efficace ça
permet à des gens qui ne sont pas
d'accord parce qu'ils anticipent ils
pensent que de pouvoir quitter la maison
donc la ligne et je laissais part merci
réponse
est en jeu je finis de préciser c'est
vraiment pour moi me faire mon opinion
mais je reprends je le comprends pas
j'ai envie de savoir ce qui s'est passé
je comprends j'aurais en gros votre
compréhension de la line éditeur
d'europe 1 jusqu'à ces événements
c'était que
c'était là même que pascal praud par
exemple c'était ça non je n'ai jamais
dit ça
sage et ça j'ai jamais dit servir
monsieur lagardère parce qu'il s'agit
mais mais mais
reconnaissez que je puisse
aimer cette émission et mais pascal
braud sans pour autant être qualifiés
d'excessifs vous voyez bon mais je vais
quand même continuer parce que vous avez
cité des noms
patrick mallet tout intrus qui se
déguise il a été nommé alors ça y est
c'était c'était l'horreur patrick maya a
été nommé à paris match en 81 il a
rejoint le groupe en 84 puisque c'est
d'elle filipacchi qui nous a amené ses
actifs il a toujours été chez nous il a
fait un passage après au figaro je crois
où il s'occupait quand je vais nommer il
s'occupait des des suppléments donc il
marchait très bien économiquement bon
alors je vois expliquez-moi le lien que
l'on peut faire entre la nomination de
patrick maye un enfant de paris match et
monsieur v et vi lundi où monsieur
bolloré faya n'a pas bon
jérôme bellay j'ai entendu un bruit
jérôme bellay forcément il travaille
pour canal+ mais ces gens là ils ont
oublié de dire qu'il a été à europe 1
c'est moi qui l'avait embauché ils ont
oublié de dire qu'il avait été déjà le
patron du jdd et subitement tout ça on
l'a oublié tout ça ces partis ailleurs
tout ça pour vous dire que ce sont des
procès d'intention de journaux de médias
eux 10 d'opinions car europe 1 n'est pas
une radio d'opinion c'est une radio
généraliste en plus pas d'information
mais généraliste et nous allons rester
une radio généraliste
alors je peux continuer tous les
présentateurs qui sont venus en europe 1
alors ça y est ils ont été traités
honnêtement de tous les non franchement
monsieur pavlenko là aussi on a oublié
qu'il est à radio classique qu'il allait
prendre la matinale ça on l'a oublié
parce qu'il était dans une émission dite
sulfureuse à ces news donc die zeit
celui-là on le met dans un coin la mieux
laurence ferrari qui est à europe 1 qui
était à tf1 qui les trois heures de
direct l'après-midi plus 8h15 sur ses
news laurence ferrari qui est une
professionnelle qui est une femme
extrêmement ouverte extrêmement
bienveillante on l'a jugé dès qu'elle
est venue de ces news en la jugeant dit
saillants lui imposer moi j'étais
premier avis franchement et quand
c'était une idée de constance baquet
pour constances m'a dit il ya une femme
qui serait formidable parce que là on
est un peu léger puis c'est quand même
avec la matinale c'est la partie qui est
important sur europe 1 on pourra faire
quelque chose de formidable et puis on
va faire avec ses news mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on s'empêcherait de le faire
avec ces news ce qui n'est pas interdit
sous prétexte que ces news appartient à
vincent bolloré pourquoi n'y a aucune
raison rmc se gêne pas bfm se gênent pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'on devrait ce génial
solu mans aucune raison et etc etc etc
messieurs les gardes permettez moi de
poser les choses un peu différemment
mais oui bien sûr peut-être n'y a pas
les mêmes pensées derrière je vais tout
à l'heure dans un propos liminaire j'ai
parlé de rapprochement éditoriale et
vous avez réagi tout bien sordide n'y a
pas de rapprochement entre alors
pourquoi ai je parlé de rapprochement
éditorial c'est en lisant en préparant
cette audition de cet après midi c'est
en lisant l'interview que vous avez fait
au jdd au mois de septembre de mémoire
vous avez dit je vous lis texto
propagande dire d'erreur je le dis au
csa il y aura des synergies fortes avec
ses news comme le fonds et vous le dit à
l'instant d'autres radios avec d'autres
télévisions bien sûr la notion de
synergies fortes assurées comme quelques
semaines plus tard il ya eu des
matinales commune entre ces news et
europe 1
c'est pour ça que moi je parle de
rapprochement éditorial
à partir du moment est ce que vous
pourriez me développer quelles sont ces
synergies et pourquoi il n'y aurait pas
de synergies éditoriales si l'optique du
rapprochement et de faire des synergies
alors il n'y a pas de reprise par ses
news à la matinale 1 sauf sauf le
dimanche pour le grand rendez breen oui
sinon la manne mois la mairie le
week-end mais
sinon on se met n'ya pas
alors pour être plus exact les synergies
que nous faisons elles sont avec le
groupe canal pas uniquement avec ses
news c'est vous qui parlez de seine-nord
jeu j'en conviens j'en conviens parce
que la question n'avait été posée par
les précisément mais j'en conviens mais
je le reprends si vous si vous le
permettez ces synergies elles sont avec
le groupe canal parce que le cinéma nous
intéresse parce que le football nous
intéresse parce que la musique nous
intéresse et là aussi nous avons des
gens qui viennent alors ils viennent pas
de ces news donc là c'est bon on peut y
aller mais ils viennent de canal+ par
exemple sur le cinéma et sur la musique
que nous utilisons et qui sont
importants aussi pour une radio
généraliste
voilà
maintenant pardon mais nous avons estimé
qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
journalistes qui pouvait venir de ses
news mais qui n'était pas uniquement sur
ces news et jean je prends l'exemple par
exemple chez nous non pas un repas mais
au jdd de béglé est encore une fois
s'autocensurer je pensais peut-être une
très mauvaise décision on a besoin de
synergies et ses synergies elles ne sont
pas éditorial elles sont aussi en terme
de visibilité voir par exemple madame
laurence ferrari être à l'antenne sur
ses news en même temps sur europe 1 puis
après seul sur europe 1 pour nous c'est
important ça vous donne une visibilité
beaucoup plus important et puis parce
que laurence ferrari est là le nom
qu'elle a la notoriété cas là le talent
qu'elle a et l'avoir sur europe 1 c'est
plutôt flatteur est ce que c'est une
chose que nous avons entendu il ya eu le
sentiment aussi que la synergie alors
sans parler de synergies éditoriales
mais en tout cas en temps d'antenne
commun à travers les matinales du
week-end comme ça se faisait
essentiellement aux bêtises il terme
bénéfices j'en trouve pas un instant
mais enfin c'est essentiellement d'aider
des journalistes de ses new skies
animait
ccc matinale commune pourquoi il n'y a
pas de on a l'impression que ça ne va
pas dans les deux sens
je crois qu'on en profite aussi beaucoup
je dis pas l'antenne jeudi les
journalistes oui mais je crois que oui
pas d'abord ce qui est étonnant bon on
s'en rend pas assez content mais les
radios ou souvent alors ça dépend
évidemment des tranches horaires mais
notamment le matin davantage d'auditeurs
que le chêne que les chaînes de télé non
de téléspectateurs on pourra faire un
million et plus là où une chaîne doit
faire 500 ou 600 mais bon c'est pas
d'heure pour les critiquer parce
qu'elles ont elles ont augmenté beaucoup
plus rapidement que l'écho les radios et
donc ça va dans les ca va dans les deux
sens le grand rendez vous par exemple ou
profitent énormément et il profita à ses
news au passage d'ailleurs le grand
rendez-vous a été instauré en 2011
avec itv donc bien avant que mais
monsieur bolloré je pense soit soit ce
que shelly lundi donc
ces choses auxquelles on a pensé depuis
très longtemps mais à ce moment là comme
il n'y avait pas monsieur bolloré on ne
parlait pas de de synergies éditoriales
la nature et pour préciser parce que le
bien entendu qu'il existe bien sûr que
vous des émissions communes depuis très
longtemps les émissions politiques du
dimanche etc se faisait avec une radio
une télé un journal et il y avait des
alliances qui se faisait comme ça
c'était pas du tout des rapprochements
au terme de deux fusions titres ou de
groupes qui ce qui est surprenant parce
que je pensais que vous posez vous
assuriez autre chose c'est que vous vous
nous le dites en fait la synergie
éditorial
c'est une collaboration sur des tranches
horaires
est-ce que vous pensez que
la marque europe un tel qu'elle vivait
tels que elle était reconnue avec avec
ses journalistes et créera à
influence
ces news ou est-ce que celle inverse à
100 je crois ni l'un ni l'autre
honnêtement dylan et le monde est resté
vraiment dans ce qu'il a toujours fait
absolument par exemple et on est toutes
ces dizaines de journalistes qui sont
partis pensent l'inversé se trompe à ce
pôle mais d'abord ils ont droit de se
tromper c'est un droit que je leur
accorde et je m'accorde à moi même aussi
effectivement je pense qu'ils ont tort
la première chute d'audience d'europe 1
c'était le matin et c'était celle de
patrick cohen patrick own c'est moi qui
les fait venir c'est moi qui l'ait vu
dans mon bureau et je me suis dit
pourquoi y ait parfois on fait des
erreurs je me suis dit avec la puissance
qui la première radio de france sur
france inter juste avant avec les à
sanaa mais je me suis dit on va
probablement récupérer peut-être pas la
totalité mais une grande partie sur
europe1 donc ça va être formidable voilà
j'étais très très heureux et la réalité
c'est que ça n'a pas pris et je ne dis
pas que ça n'a pas pris à cause de lui
je dis que ça n'a pas pris parce que ça
n'était pas forcément le bon format et
ça a été la preuve puisque on en revient
la concentration que ceux qui jouent
beaucoup aussi sur une matinale
la capacité d'une radio qu'elle a à se
faire entendre s'il ya des régions qui
n'écoutent pas ils ne sont pas mesurés
et donc forcément la fameuse équipe à 22
joueurs ça joue parce que le patrick
cohen d'europe 1 était le même que le
patrick cohen de france inter et ça n'a
pas marché
le concept dans cette commission il ya
eu un petit moment où on a eu une
information corrige et ensuite qu'on se
quand on a auditionné monsieur bernard
arnault oui je lui ai posé la question
aussi où il avait
fait une offre d'achat
le jdd paris match dans un premier temps
et l'a dit non mais la corriger
immédiatement ensuite d'intégrer sa
correction
pourquoi donc si cette offre dans votre
réflexion vous avez choisi vivendi par
rapport à cette offre ag a choisi lundi
j'ai choisi de la garder dans le groupe
lagardère c'est totalement différent et
cette offre avait été faite avant que
organise cette paix entre tous les
actionnaires mais pas avec monsieur
bernard arnault mais surtout avec amber
capitale est un des actes fondateurs de
cette paix actionnariale ça a été des
actifs qui sont dans le groupe lagardère
reste dans le groupe lagardère dont
europe 1 ne sort pas jdd ne sont pas
match ne sort pas il reste dans le
groupe la g
parole à jean raymond gueuler
merci monsieur le président c'est
lagardère bonjour bonjour si vous ne
l'aviez pas fait je ne l'aurais pas fait
mais comme vous avez évoqué la mémoire
de votre père je voulais juste vous dire
en préambule que
j'avais bien connue votre père que pour
moi il est associé à jean permet le toit
ce qui est un estonien qui était un
estonien un arrêt à l'épopée matra et à
une entreprise qui était dans ma commune
dans laquelle fut toujours conseiller
municipal qui s'appelait comme elin et
qui était plus voilà de l'entreprise
vous avez rappelé cette saga familiale
la fidélité à l'héritage et le sexe les
héritages sont parfois lourds quand on a
un père pareil
et vous avez su avec
beaucoup de sérénité de tranquillité
assumer parfaitement cet héritage n'en
déplaise à ceux qui forcément on
essayait de trouver à votre encontre des
critiques aussi stupide
que malveillantes
paris match et europe 1 jdd c'est la
france
tout le monde se gobergent depuis le coc
vide de la souveraineté industrielle
française que vous et votre famille
incarné comme d'autres familles qui sont
passées devant cette commission denquête
comme toujours dans notre pays la
réussite est suspecte
elle génère la malveillance et
l'amertume de la part de gens qui n'ont
jamais réussi à faire cela
et c'est interroge véritablement non
seulement ça interroge mais je peux vous
le dire
ça ça peut énerver au plus haut point
mais question sont très simples est ce
que vous auriez une définition puisque
tout ce que vous avez dit cher monsieur
est très claire on le croit ou on ne le
crois pas c'est son intime conviction ce
qui me concerne je le crois
auriez vous une définition du pluralisme
et une définition de l'honnêteté de
l'information
mon dieu
alors d'abord je remercie pour vos
propos jour on remercie d'autant que
je les entends assez peu donc ça fait
toujours du bien à entendre évidemment
c'est je l'espère j'essaie de m'en
convaincre en tout cas mais
j'aurais pu
mille fois cédé ce groupe mille fois
j'aurais pu le cda beaucoup de gens qui
me proposait des sommes très importantes
je serais probablement aujourd'hui
peut-être moins heureux sûrement
mais peut-être à la tête d'une fortune
plus importante j'ai décidé en 2006 un
peu comment on va au casino de faire
banco et de dire allez je mets tout dans
l'entreprise tout absolument tout
demande était un point vous n'imaginez
pas peut-être que vous imaginez
plusieurs centaines de millions et
d'acheter les titres de cette entreprise
un crs étaient pas forcément de bon
moment parce que c'était à 60 euros un
bi aujourd'hui à 24 sepa sepa 26 mai
parce que je croyais à cette entreprise
et parce que j'y crois j'y crois
toujours donc ce choix de l'entreprise
ce choix de l'héritage c'est comme ça
que je le conçois et c'est vrai que j'ai
beaucoup lu et je je
ça me rend triste mais qu'une certaine
france
n'aime pas ça n'aime pas les héritiers
mais je me souviens de cette phrase et
vous connaissez mon père donc vous la
reconnaîtrez sûrement très très bien
cette phrase il me disait toujours et
c'est à l'époque il y avait pas de
réseaux sociaux ne bâtit jamais ton
bonheur est en équilibre personnel et
professionnel à travers le regard des
autres jamais c'est ce qui l'a
d'ailleurs tout fait et mon père a été
traitée absolument de tous les noms et
subitement le 14 mars 2003 le jour de
son décès c'est devenu l'immense
industrielle que j'ai toujours connu et
qu'il a toujours été bon voilà on sait
ce genre de choses c'est l'avis des
chefs d'entreprise c'est la vie des
hommes politiques c'est la vie des
sportifs cc c'est comme ça
à partir de là le pluralisme il n'est
pas uniquement incarnée par les
journalistes même s'il l'est aussi mais
il est aussi incarné par les gens les
femmes et les hommes qui les invités qui
s'exprime on n'a jamais interdit qui que
ce soit à europe 1 ni au jdd ni à
matches dans le passé dans le présent et
dans le futur jamais absolument jamais
donc c'est un reproche qu'on ne peut pas
nous faire et je trouve dommage qu'on
nous fasse un autre reproche en avant
deux phases en disant oui mais bon
peut-être aller on veut bien vous
accorder sa encore que il ya quelques
exemples qui parlent contre vous mais
mais l'avenir vous voyez bien ça va pas
être comme ça j'ai lu sa droite à gauche
vous êtes dans le déni monsieur
lagardère vous êtes un peu je les lui
comme cette femme trompée voyez n'osent
pas le dire peut pas le dire parce
qu'elle en a honte et que c'était bon et
c'est dommage mais c'est on est à des
années lumière de la réalité des choses
à des années lumière et ça ça me rend
malgré tout un petit peu un petit peu
triste mais en tout cas pas du tout
aigri et donc l'ambition elle reste là
le pluralisme restera là
j'en n'ai absolument aucun doute aucun
doute parce que moi je fais confiance à
des amis de trente ans et on a eu
l'occasion vincent et moi des changé
beaucoup de choses il m'a énormément
aidé comme d'autres amis le jour du
décès de mon père énormément aidés
moralement et ça c'est des choses qui
comptent c'est des choses qu'on peut pas
oublier et ça montre aussi une certaine
forme de sincérité il a fait des choses
qu'il était absolument pas obligés de
faire est totalement gratuitement
d'ailleurs sens en contrepartie donc
donc j'ai une totale confiance et
j'espère que cette commission reverra le
jour dans cinq ans dix ans peut-être je
ne sais pas j'espère avec les mêmes
personnes et puis qu'on en reparlera à
ce moment là non pas en avance non pas
en disant voilà ce qu'il va se passer
mais voilà ce qui s'est passé réellement
dans les fêtes non parce qu'on pense que
tout ce que certains médias d'opinion
imagine donc voilà je je je je ne sais
pas quoi vous dire de plus
alors moi j'ai fait énormément d'erreurs
bien évidemment j'en ai fait beaucoup
mais je pense que mes équipes me
rattraper souvent et franchement si je
devais laisser un jour un héritage
comme celui là à voir ces deux branches
et surtout la branche du livre en tête
tant le podium est à la première place
mondiale je me dirais aller après tout
on s'en fout tout ça des critiques et
ccc ccc la vie c'est normal si je
faisais parce j'étais pas passionné par
ce métier je le ferai pas et je le ferai
pas dans ce pays mais mais quand même
c'est beau d'avoir réalisé ça c'est beau
et je vous assure je vous le redis c'est
dommage que vous n'y étiez pas là
présent en 2003 l'année du décès de mon
père mais cette idée de réduire la
taille du groupe pour leur faire grandir
elle est est évidente déjà à ce moment
là et le constat il était évident je
vous assure il était évident on serait
nulle part aujourd'hui si on avait gardé
ce fameux ce fameux conglomérat là cet
empire de lagardère qui a été soi disant
détruit on serait plus là on n'aurait
rien hachette serait dilapidé le travel
retail n'existerait pas quant à nos
médias je ne sais pas où là où il serait
je suis patient j'ai d'ailleurs bien
répondu à votre question mais votre
préliminaire m'a fait tellement plaisir
je me suis le seul qui peut aller donc
et je veux bien d'autres comme ça
bonjour madame bonjour madame voilà vous
dites que cette future au pied à amical
entre familles et amis seraient dans le
but de renforcer et de grandir oui c'est
beau propos vous avez dit également en
garde le groupe car je suis rassuré est
assurée oui que l'intégrité du groupe le
management la stratégie de développement
seront telles quelles fins moi je vais
vous poser la question à savoir qu'elle
garde fous vous allez me justement pour
pouvoir affirmer justement que
l'intégrité du groupe le management sera
telle qu'elle est comment pouvez-vous
rassurer les salariés les journalistes
qui reste justement par rapport à cette
opé amical et par rapport aux propos que
vous avez tenus alors madame les
garde-fous en réalité ils aiguisent
n'existe pas ou peu c'est d'abord la
confiance que l'on peut avoir en
quelqu'un parce que comme vous le savez
un chef d'entreprise
et même d'ailleurs avec la commandite il
est révocable à du tome alors - av du
tome dans une commandite m'enfin en bout
de six ans l'échéance revient la même et
finalement c'est pas plus mal parce que
c'est une certaine me dit
motivation vous êtes des élus du peuple
vous savez bien que bon ça peut aller
comme ça peut ne pas la laisser comme ça
on a un bilan à rendre compte si le
bilan est conforme ya aucune raison que
ça se passe mal s'il n'est pas conforme
et bien vous en subissez les
conséquences maintenant sur l'aspect
confiance que je peux avoir vis-à-vis
non seulement de monsieur vincent
bolloré de ses enfants et du management
de viven dit je vous le dis vraiment
droit dans les yeux j'y crois j'y crois
parce que je connais ces personnes et
parce que si je puis me permettre c'est
aussi dans l'intérêt de viven dit que
les choses se passent bien dans ce sens
là et que économiquement le groupe
lagardère contribuer à au développement
aussi de viven dis donc c'est un c'est
un jeu à somme positive pour tout le
monde absolument pour tout le monde
alors évidemment on peut toujours douter
de quelqu'un toujours mais l'expérience
nous montre et vous savez j'ai très peu
d'amis ce qui me permet d'ailleurs de
palme en méfier très très peu mais cela
ils sont vraiment solides et j'ai pu à
l'épreuve du feu pendant une trentaine
d'années s'est beaucoup 30 ans c'est
beaucoup
j'ai pu le voir le mesurer et je suis je
suis au fur et à mesure les jours
avancent en et les questions marivan je
suis de plus en plus conscients et
convaincus que les choses vont bien se
passer dans l'intérêt de tout le monde
mais je ne suis pas là pour convaincre
parce que je suis convaincue mais
peut-être l avantage par rapport à vous
madame de connaître mieux les personnes
dont je parle
michel laugier merci mais c'est le
président de lagardère bonjour bonjour
vga 2 de toutes vos réponses est ce que
vous êtes j'ai répondu une partie de mes
questions mais
dans dans la vision aujourd'hui mona de
de la concentration des médias il ya
deux aspects toujours il ya l'aspect
économique et après il ya la pluralité
et l'expression démocratique aussi au
niveau des journalistes alors est-ce que
selon vous vous avez su préserver dans
vos médias l'indépendance des rédactions
et comment et pensez vous que ce sera
encore possible dans les années qui
viennent avec tes nouvelles
configurations et bien sûr la deuxième
question c'est on vous sent vraiment
attaché à littéralement attachés à vos
médias et notamment europe 1 vous avez
beaucoup parlé alors on est vous êtes
attachés et
expliquez nous comment on a pu assister
finalement une perte d'audience aussi
catastrophique ça c'est ma deuxième est
question
23e vous dites que vous êtes rassurés
sur l'avenir de vos médias parce que
vous allez toujours avoir un certain
contrôle est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
serez amené
encore avoir d'autres projets avec
peut-être des médias nouvelle génération
plus tourné vers le digital voilà qu'est
ce qu'on quels sont vos projets en ce
domaine est avec moi d'être visées par
une boutade vous aimez l'émission de
pascal praud laurent joffrin intervient
dans cette émission est ce que vous êtes
proche de ligne éditoriale de monsieur
joffrin mai mais j'aime cette émission
parce que j'aime laurent joffrin ça vous
l'avez vous l'avez évidemment compris et
d'ailleurs il y va donc lui ça lui pose
pas de problème et d'ailleurs ça pète ça
donne un ton à l'émission qui est qui et
qui est formidable il va plus le matin
que le soir donc je le vois je le vois
moins mais mais mais
je me suis demandée avant si c'était
bien de vous le dire je suis dieu après
allez on est sous serment je vois pas
pourquoi ce cas se mentir par omission
c'est mentir tout court donc je me suis
dit allez je vous accorde ce point là
alors beaucoup de questions
d'abord attaché à europe 1 et malgré
tout pourquoi avoir laissé entre
guillemets fils et
repeints
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est une probablement une une somme
d'erreurs que j'assume si je doit les
assumer seule les assumer seul
est ce que c'est le fait d'avoir mis
trop peu d'informations parce qu'on met
davantage d'informations aujourd'hui
c'est possible est ce que il y avait
toute une génération qui est parti alors
là pour le coup non pas qu'ils ont
souhaité partir mais par l'âge
qui nous manque aujourd'hui
même si on a gardé quelques grandes voix
c'est possible aussi
le virage du numérique on l'a pris trop
tard c'est clair on voit d'ailleurs
maintenant le nombre croissant de gens
qui écoutent la radio avec leur mobile
et c'est une bonne chose ce virage on a
pris trop tard et je
j'avoue que j'ai pas vu le coup passé
assez vite ça je m'en veux
et puis à un moment aussi voyez à force
de vouloir gérer au plus serré je pense
qu'on a on aurait dû investir davantage
probablement dans la dans la rédaction
probablement avec des des journalistes à
l'étranger ce qu'on n'a pas voulu faire
parce qu'on sentait déjà que les profits
commencé à diminuer diminué diminué donc
je me suis attaqué à la base de coûts ce
qui était probablement pas le bon moment
pour le faire j'ai pas été assez patient
probablement donc ça c'est aussi une
autre raison
et puis il ya eu des nouveaux entrants
et puis pardonnez moi je vais le dire
parce que je leur dis aussi en face le
sait ça ne nous a absolument pas aidé au
contraire alors qu'il fasse à dire
qu'ils crèvent un terreau petit mais
quand vous dites laisser ça ne nous a
pas aidés oui alors qu'il crée un
nouveau réseau je peux comprendre ça a
été le cas aussi dans la téléphonie
ça a fait du mal aux anciens et puis
finalement tout le monde s'y retrouve et
que c'est a donc créé un réseau comme
comme rmc on en voit l'utilité
aujourd'hui dans la pluralité c'est un
grand succès bravo alain weil rien à
dire bon mais là on a perdu beaucoup de
2 de croissance dans les aimer et qui à
chaque fois
je ne critique aucune personne mais à
chaque fois qu'il y avait des
autorisations qui étaient disponibles
j'ai senti alors peut-être que je me
trompe je suis prudent dans ce que je
dis mais j'ai senti qu'on était pas
vraiment favorisé voilà que le public
était davantage que nous et que d'autres
stations de radio l'était davantage que
nous voilà ça c'est côté un peu mauvais
joueur mais que je n'utiliserai qu'une
seule fois parce qu'encore une fois je
vous le dis je vous le répète je
j'assume j'assume ces échecs bon voilà
je regrette autant que vous et c'est
pour ça que maintenant je m'attelle à
faire en sorte que les choses se passent
se passe un peu mieux alors vous m'avez
aussi posé une question sur les médias
nouvelle génération julien j'en ai un
peu répondu on n'est pas dans une
dans une configuration où nous allons
acquérir des journaux ni acquérir
d'autres radios alors vous avez cité
monsieur le président rfm c'est exact
nous avons aussi virgin et là on a comme
on dirait un espèce de pool de trois
radios qui nous donnent des synergies
publicitaires qui sont pas négligeables
l'idée n'est pas de racheter d'autres
radios l'idée de l'es2 gérer celle là du
mieux que l'on pourra et de redresser le
plus vite possible europe 1
par contre oui s'il ya des
investissements à faire et ça c'est ce
qu'on a vu très récemment dans le groupe
dans nos budgets à 3 ans dans le dans le
numérique on a prévu une somme assez
coquette de 2,2 d'investissements dans
le numérique que ce soit à travers les
applications
bon la distribution du jdd est un autre
sujet le dimanche est évidemment un
sujet qui nous préoccupe il nous occupe
beaucoup là aussi la sortie par le haut
si je puis dire c'est le numérique il
faut qu'on fasse davantage pour le jdd
sur le numérique ce qu'on fait mais bon
ça toujours un petit côté agréable aller
chercher son journal
à la boulangerie le matin mais c'est
malheureusement de moins en moins le cas
je reste positif à terme économiquement
sur sur ce pôle et c'est pour ça que je
me dis finalement je crois que le
rapporteur rappeler très justement que
les pertes d'europe 1 était quand même
même si c'est peut-être l'épaisseur du
trait pour l'ensemble du groupe c'est
pas rien c'est exact mais justement si
c'est pas rien ça vaut la peine qu'on
s'y attelle et je ne cèderai pas europe
a passé la parole au sénateur capitaine
dubois monsieur le président mais j'ai
pas répondre à cette question là vous
mais pas répond à la tâche et où
l'indépendance des journalistes comment
vous avez pratiqué avec quels moyens et
comment vous le voyez pour les années à
venir on a absolument
pardonnez moi mais tout ce qu'il faut on
a une charte de déontologie
on a évidemment cette clause de
conscience et de cession
on peut regarder mais je ne crois pas
que constance benqué soit franchement
une femme d'une autorité
excessive elle est extrêmement
bienveillante elle prend le temps de
parler avec les gens elle les consulte
alors elle se fait souvent critiqués
mais franchement on ne peut pas la
critique est là dessus bon et j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour reprendre un
terme que vous m'avez sites est monsieur
le monsieur le rapporteur lorsque
monsieur donald vidal revel dit que les
salaires sont payés par monsieur bolloré
c'est une bourde une banque que j'ai pas
apprécié parce que c'est faux et parce
que ses bêtes voilà et
j'ajoute quand même parce que tout ceci
va être repris immédiatement comme
monsieur daniel vidal revel a toute ma
confiance je peux me permettre voilà non
pas pour ce qu'il a dit mais pour tout
ce qui fait par ailleurs
pardonnez moi je vais avant de passer la
parole au sénateur capo-canellas ce
juste rebondir sur une question que
vient de vous poser la théologie et
concernant les qui vous l'avez abordé en
partie mais je voudrais que vous alliez
un peu plus loin pour que notre
compréhension soit au total sur la
question économique et du redressement
d'une radio comme europe 1 ça ne pas là
pour juger mais pour comprendre
si je schématise peut-être que ce sera
trop schématique compléterait mai et
économiquement une radio cd recettes qui
sont publicitaires et puis des coups qui
sont follement essentiellement ce lieu
se lier à la grille
à une des tables rondes ici même sur des
recettes publicitaires est bon
les perspectives en tout cas côté radio
ne sont pas forcément très favorable en
termes de recettes publicitaires
ou au mieux ce sera une stagnation et au
pire une baisse dans ces conditions
comment peut-on redresser une radio
comme européens économiquement encore
une fois si ce n'est à travers des
économies sur la grille est dense et
quel type d'économie sans toucher à la
qualité
de de la radio à l'information aux
émissions aux intervenantes oui il est
certain que gérer une entreprise
uniquement sur les coûts ça ça et on le
voit aujourd'hui sa présente des dangers
ça c'est clair alors d'abord il ya
d'autres sources de revenus europe1 peut
avoir les podcasts notamment qui marche
extrêmement bien qui sont donc issus de
deux journalistes
de la station on l'a par exemple
marche extraordinairement bien ce sont
des choses sur lesquelles que l'on peut
monétiser donc ça c'est extrêmement
positif et puis il ya les parts de
marché rien ne nous empêche d'être
meilleur que les autres de garder
davantage de gagner davantage on part de
marché ce qui va augmenter les recettes
c'était en réalité ça notre objectif
c'est de passer des fameux 4% et
quelques aujourd'hui on il ya des
sondages bientôt à 5 pourquoi pas si
cette ce sont des industries à économie
bas coûts fixes donc évidemment une fois
qu'on est passé au dessus des coûts
fixes de la somme des coûts fixes ça
peut aller très vite dans le bon sens et
est donc il faut augmenter les recettes
je pense que sur les coûts
on a on a fait le tour je pense qu'on a
fait le tour
alors pour passer des 4 à 5 etc c'est
dans la qualité des programmes c'est
toucher les gens c'est les sondages que
l'on peut faire c'est la qualité des
journalistes etc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a on a changé et par exemple
aux avenir je fais une obsession sur le
15 19
plutôt sur le 18-20 excusez moi mais on
voit quand même que cette tranche lac
notre deuxième tranche importante en
termes de recettes publicitaires
après le matin est en train de bien
bouger et ça bouge bien parce que là
aussi c'est une forme de synergie ou de
partenariat avec ses news et ça avec
laurence ferrari ça nous aide laurence
ferrari par exemple fait la dernière
partie seule sur europe 1 et elle est
avant sur europe 1 et ses news et j'ai
la faiblesse de penser que quand on est
sur ces news on est peut-être intéressé
aussi à continuer avec laurence ferrari
peut-être pas très gentil pour pour
l'autre émission sur ses news mais bon
c'est ce sont ce genre de choses des
personnes qui ont la notoriété et qui
vont attirer des gens puisque notre vous
les aviez avant vous en aviez d'autres
pas cela mais vous aviez d'autres non
oui bien sûr de louer et d'autres qui
sur leur nom vous faisait deux raisons
non mais vous avez raison bien sûr c'est
pour ça je vous dis on n'est jamais à
l'abri de faire de commettre une erreur
c'est ce que je vous dis mais à partir
du moment où on a souhaité
s'engager davantage sur une radio
généraliste mais qui donne davantage de
parts à l'information notamment le matin
puisque maintenant que nous n'avons plus
canteloup il n'est pas remplacé par un
autre par un autre humoriste donc c'est
bien c'est bien la preuve que ce n'est
pas monsieur canteloup qui posait
problème ils n'osaient pas d'ailleurs
mais donc on a souhaité faire un format
qui est un format plus
d'information et de débat parce qu'on
estimait que c'était plus dans le l'état
d'esprit qu'europe 1 pouvait avoir ce
qui n'empêche pas qu'on a un matthieu
noël à
cet arrêt car enfin bon on a un peu plus
tard à 18h45 bon on n'a pas abandonné
cette ligne là non plus vous nous dites
formellement votre réponse oui vous me
dire d'ailleurs oui comme monsieur que
tout c'est pas parce qu'il a moqué
monsieur bolloré quoi de condat jugé que
c'était plus une émission que c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui ramenait de
l'audience et qui aimait oui vous avez
bien sûr donc se débarrasser comme ça
quand on quand on est une radio qui on
est en perte d'audience et c'est pas la
première chose à laquelle on pense de
2,2 dira au revoir monsieur contre nous
vous me confirmer que ça n'a aucun
rapport vous savez s'il savait s'il y
avait un problème éditoriale avec
monsieur quand louche prend son sens
serait séparé depuis longtemps parce que
avant monsieur bolloré encore il n'a pas
manqué souvent j'étais probablement dans
l'est dans le top 3 des personnes qu'ils
qui taquinaient si je puis dire
peut-être que vous supportez mur
monsieur bolloré non non non non je
personnes ne supportent ça c'est juste
voilà la pluralité comme vous le dites
et puis vous rend vie avec et je ne
pense pas que monsieur canteloup
d'ailleurs enfin je l'espère parce que
ce serait comment dirais-je décevant de
sa part dit ce qu'il a été évincé pour
des raisons éditoriales
il a toujours eu la liberté éditoriale
toujours toujours toujours vincent capo
canellas toujours merci monsieur le
président monsieur regardez vous parliez
instants de repos qui est une belle et
grande radio et vous avez de très beaux
médias effectivement avec paris match
jeudi des européens en particulier qui
font partie c'est vrai la vie des
français bon alors européen on est tous
un peu désespérée quand on voit les
chutes d'audience c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
et puis on sait que vous êtes dans cette
stratégie d'alliance avec un 10 qui se
défend alors cette commission cette
enquête qui a été initiée par les
groupes socialistes s'intéresse aux
effets des concentrations sur le
pluralisme alors tout à l'heure à la
question de mon collègue jean raymond
huguenin sur le pluralisme vous avez
d'abord répondu que c'était pour parler
des journalistes
et puis également du choix des invités
qui devait illustrer le pluralisme
moi j'ai une question qui intéresse en
particulier europe 1 vous avez tout
comprendre de qui je veux parler est ce
que le fait de remplacer des
journalistes par des essayistes des
penseurs comme on les présente à
l'antenne des personnes sur une ligne
politique qui défendent dans leurs
questions et clearwire des tribunes sur
ses news oui défendent une ligne
politique très
identifiée
est-ce que ça c'est c'est une façon
d'illustrer le pluralisme
cela vous ne répondez suprême c'est
d'abord les journalistes et ses choix
des invités et là on se dit c'est
curieux comme le grand rendez vous sur
trois personnes qui interroge janin qui
semble-t-il présenté comme sociologue et
essayiste penseur mais qui semble pas
être un journaliste et qui est toujours
dans la même thématique bon voilà est-ce
que c'est pas une perte de sens à pour
europe 1 est-ce que ça répond à
l'exigence de pluralisme
et un sur trois déjà c'est du pluralisme
un sur trois parce que les deux autres
personnes sont donc notre autre
partenaire les échos généralement c'est
monsieur bart est qui et qui est
on peut pas dire qu'il ait une ligne
particulière
et sonia mabrouk alors vous aimez bien
abstenu malraux qu'elle et ses news
women et à europe 1 avant elle a fait le
trajet en sens inverse où les donc et
elle et elle est plus que légitime et
pitié ne nous touchait pas à sonia
mabrouk le matin elle est vraiment très
très utile elle fait un travail
formidable et et on en a vraiment besoin
donc ne nous l'a déstabilisé pas si je
peux dire elle ne mérite pas en plus
maintenant voilà c'est un c'est un choix
qui n'est pas de mon fait c'est un choix
qui n'est pas du fait de qui que ce soit
chez dit lundi je pense que c'est même
pas un choix du fait de de constance
benqué c'est cette émission c'est
probablement le choix de sonia mabrouk
était de donner vidal revel etc bon
voila mais une personne sur trois oui
c'est du pluralisme je vous retourne un
pur le le
le le problème si je peux dire
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas mais moi
je suis pas là pour dire si j'aime ou
j'aime pas c'est pas mon sujet c'est pas
mon rôle non plus
celui de lundi
oui donc
gros on retiendra deux éléments de dans
ce que vous dites est un élément
important c'est qu'en réalité pour des
raisons de contexte économique de deux
choix financier de protection de ce que
vous aviez jusqu'à présent vous avez
vous accepté
de céder
à bolloré vous avez des nouvelles
d'ailleurs de loupé à quel moment dans
on nous avait dit février oui je pense
que ça n'en très honnêtement non mais je
pense ce sera oui bon février on est
déjà à mi février mais ce sera ce sera
bientôt et oui et puis après il ya une
période il doit y avoir un document qui
est déposé à la mf la mer à une certaine
période notre conseil doit se soucie se
prononcer à la fois sur le pea et puis
sur le prix et puis après le père est
lancée je crois qu'il ya une semaine une
fenêtre d'à peu près un mois donc ce
sera dans les mois à venir à peu près
d'un mois où les gens décident
d'apporter ou de ne pas apporter et en
ce qui me concerne je n'apporterai pas
ça c'est une 500c mars oui ça devrait
être ça mais je ne veux pas vous dire
des choses qui sont en plus sous serment
je vais pas vous dire des choses qui
sont qui ne sont pas strictement exact
je vais pas poursuivre parce qu on a
oublié une pelade qui veut vous poser
une question j'ai je reviens oui on
reviendra sur l'édition aussi parce que
j'ai
c'est ça oui ok ok j'ai oublié évident
rodo garabédian
je veux m'excuser auprès d'elle
non ce n'est pas évident de garabédian
mais sylvie robert
oui merci
monsieur lagardère je vais revenir
justement que votre deux autres formes
de concentration mais qui forcément des
impacts à la fois en termes de publicité
de promotion de diversité de liberté
la première et c'est l'un des aspects de
cet opéra qui passe un peu inaperçu mais
c'est la concentration qui pourraient en
découler dans le domaine du spectacle
vivant
est ce que on va vers un modèle aux 360
degrés où toutes les formes de
production distribution et billetterie
serait gérée par un même acteur donc
j'aimerais avoir votre votre point de
vue sur cette forme de concentration et
puis puisqu'on en a parlé hier et vous y
êtes revenu à l'instant la question du
rapprochement entre hachette editis
qui vous le savez suscite beaucoup
d'inquiétude en particulier chez les
salariés mais pas seulement et dans
l'hypothèse où ce projet passerait on va
dire les fourches caudines de coups de
sel comment allez vous gérer la
problématique des centres de
distribution calvo quels sont votre quel
est votre projet en la matière parce que
ce qu'on sait aussi que ça va poser un
certain nombre de questions dont voilà à
la fois spectacle vivant et édition mais
on sait que même si nous parlons
concentration des médias ces phénomènes
de concentration deux sont liés par un
certain nombre d'impacts quelle qu'elles
génèrent voilà je vous remercie beaucoup
de votre réponse merci madame alors sur
le spectacle vivant pour pour rappeler
un petit peu le périmètre que nous avons
nous allons effectivement un certain
nombre de deux salles à paris nous avons
par exemple le casino de paris où on va
faire de notre prochaine assemblée on a
les folies bergères aussi on en a en
province à bordeaux qui est une salle
enfin dans la métropole de bordeaux qui
est une salle qui marche très bien à aix
aussi et dans cette activité on
représente un certain nombre d'artistes
pas beaucoup on est des tout petits
petits acteurs par rapport à des
américains comme livenation etc
de son côté vivendi a évidemment le
mythique olympia
c'est évidemment tout le monde
souhaiterait avoir l'olympia qui est
formidable et alors là pour le coup
on n'a jamais même par le passé
d'ailleurs essayé quelques
synergies ou quelques discussions que ce
soit ni avant l'entrée de devis lundi à
notre capital ni pendant ni en ce moment
jamais à aucun moment
bon alors il ya d'autres acteurs que
vous connaissez sûrement
il ya des gros acteurs européens
l'acteur allemand qui doit représenter
une valorisation entre 2 et 3 milliards
alors que nous on fait péniblement
70 80 millions de chiffre d'affaires et
puis à beaucoup de petits acteurs en
france qu'il faut évidemment protégés
qui ont des petits théâtres ici et là
mais sur lesquelles on n'est pas
franchement en concurrence en tout cas
pas pour ce qui nous concerne on est
dans des jauges qui sont entre 800 et
1200 1300 personnes
donc ce ne sont pas des salles immenses
pour faire bon quand même le folies
bergères un petit peu plus je crois et
on n'a absolument pas aborder ce sujet
je suis pas sûr que ce soit un sujet
d'ailleurs de 2 pour la concurrence mais
si ça doit l'être on prendra les mesures
les mesures qu'il faut si vous voulez
mais absolument pas alors concernant
achète et editis pour ça c'est un vaste
sujet je ne sais pas si je me réponds
tout de suite assez oui
et au fur et à mesure
je peux vous faire une réponse très
rapide qu'elle vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
je suis autorisé à ne rien vous dire
pour la bonne et simple raison que 1 ce
n'est pas moi qui vais décider ce n'est
pas vive un 10 qui m'a décidée ce sont
les autorités à bruxelles et on les
connaît les autorités à bruxelles on n'y
a été en 2003 2004 j'avais d'ailleurs
négocier tout ça avec monsieur mario
monti et
on s'était pas évidemment facile alors
entre 2003 et aujourd'hui le monde a
beaucoup changé alors je sais qu'il est
le bon temps ici de vous dire ne vous
trompez pas d'ennemis l'ennemi il n'est
pas en france l'ennemi c'est les gars
femmes je sais qu'à un grand éditeur
s'élève vous avez dit je crois hier que
les gars femme s'était pas un problème
alors je suis pas un grand joueur de
scrabble mais je sais qu'en gars familia
2a et même s'ils savent aucun point au
scrabble dans notre vie à nous ça vaut
énormément ses amazones et c'est pas
rien et on veut on peut pas dire que
finalement mozo non ce n'est pas grave
je crois qu'une ancienne ministre a dit
aussi non pas ici mais dans la presse
que toute manière amazonie sont grands
ya rien à faire et c'est non nous on
n'est pas comme ça on dit pas qui a rien
à faire et je ne dis pas non plus qu'il
faut lutter contre amazon parce qu'ils
ont leur rôle aussi à jouer et c'est un
client va pas se fâcher avec son client
enfin vous voyez l'idée là pour le coup
d'une vraie concentration vous aviez
vous avez quand même 10 ennemis oui non
jeune j'ai dit oui j'ai dit que l'ennemi
il n'était pas en france il était
ailleurs
exact mais c'est quand même notre client
et donc on lui doit le respect et
d'ailleurs nous doit le respect aussi
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que la vraie concentration dans ce
métier serait que le distributeur est
une velléité d'être aussi est dit et de
se dire mais finalement l'éditeur il
sert à quoi emplir pas grand chose moi
je voulais prendre aux auteurs je prends
les manuscrits je les imprime je les
distribue et puis et puis voilà le
pilote le tout réglé or on sait
aujourd'hui que le métier d'éditeur est
de plus en plus à une véritable valeur
ajoutée et que l'auteur puisque c'est
lui qui est au centre de tout ça silva
chez un éditeur c'est pas pour rien
c'est pas pour gagner moins d'argent par
rapport à ce que pourraient
éventuellement lui proposait amazon
c'est qu'il ya une valeur ajoutée en
termes de marketing et pilar le lien
entre l'éditeur et l'auteur est toujours
magique c'est toujours un couple
extrêmement important et qui valorise
d'ailleurs toujours le l'auteur donc
notre place on la défend mordicus et je
ne vois pas pourquoi il ne serait
interdit d'avoir de l'ambition même en
france
au nom d'une pseudo comment dirais-je
concentration qu'il de toute manière
sera réglé par bruxelles
ça sert à rien de crier avant d'avoir
mal elle sera réglée à bruxelles
attendons que bruxelles se servent ils
se saisissent du dossier et puis on
verra après est-ce que ça a été pré
notifié je ne crois pas pas encore je ne
crois pas mais ça sent il indique qu'il
auprès de sa rue mais comme vous êtes
l'interlocuteur sur ces sujets et non à
l'oppression on peut parler on ne peut
pas se parler hein on a ce qu'on appelle
un clean rom dans lequel on s'échange
des données mais on ne peut pas négocié
entre nous bien évidemment bien
évidemment peut-être juste une formation
probablement broxeele une façon d'une
eau je ne sais pas à quelle hauteur dira
qu' il y à des secteurs qui devra
ne pas être fondus qui devrait être
vendu ça c'est évident
vous avez déjà réfléchir à ce que dans
ce cas là vous c'est deriez en priorité
à quoi vous tenez le mois où house que
vous vous sentirez le plus obligé de le
céder dans ce cas là des idées je je je
peux en avoir je ne veux pas les données
aujourd'hui parce que d'abord il faut
que je les quantifie ensuite
il faut que j'attends les étapes les
unes après les autres puis ce serait
quand même pas très élégant vis-à-vis de
la commission de d'en parler
contrairement à ce que font nos amis
mais oui je pense que vivendi a aussi
une idée claire de ce qu'ils voudraient
eux même gardé de leur côté cédé
j'imagine si la liste est triste robert
poser la question des diffuseurs
distributeurs c'est qu'on a bien compris
que c'était difficile de scinder les
éditeurs des maisons d'édition des
diffuseurs et des distributeurs est-ce
que de ce point de vue là vous vous avez
une solution ou
il y aura sûrement des solutions
pardonnez moi je ne fuis pas la question
mais je ne veux pas l'anticiper non plus
même si elle est d'actualité en ce
moment parce que d'abord le tout c'est
dans la main de villain dit en ce moment
et qu'ensuite il sera toujours temps de
d'en discuter je veux pas que les gens
soient chez editis et surtout chercher
chez nous
anticipe des ddd des catastrophes des
cessions des découpages même si on sait
qu'il ya des secteurs dans lesquels on
sera
extrêmement dominant qui pourrait poser
problème à bruxelles bon maintenant
quand je vois
tf1 rtl m6 à 70 % de parts de marché à
la télé je me sens un peu mieux quand
même
mais bon c'est une petite actrice si
vous me permettez on en a l'eau ça on a
le droit sous serment on a le droit la
colline renault garabédian
non monsieur arnaud en début de semaine
nous avons notamment auditionner
certains dossiers le journaliste de
donner celle du journal du dimanche oui
et celle de paris match oui ils ont
estimé que votre groupe avait raté le
virage je ne fais que de citer avait
raté le virage du numérique et n'avait
pas suffisamment investi pour assurer
une transition et qui a modifié comme
tout le monde le sait les médias en
profondeur partagez vous cet avis
j'aurai une deuxième question à vous
poser qui concerne la garenne lagardère
travaux laurie telle qu'ils la seconde
branche de votre secteur d'activité vous
disposez de plus de 1000 points de vente
dans l'ue du transport en france ainsi
que dans les pays étrangers au travers
des magasins relais vient de cette
activité pendant la période passée
notamment en raison du coc vide soit
devenue déficitaire est ce que cette
structure va continuer à innover pour
proposer de nouvelles offres et quel est
l'avenir de cette branche sachant que
bernard anneaux arnault s'est dit
intéressé par ce secteur d'activité
merci de vos réponses réponse de
monsieur lagardère c'est monsieur arnaud
et monsieur bernard
alors
je je je crois avoir un peu anticipée
votre première question et j'ai
effectivement reconnu alors j'ai reconnu
plus sur europe 1 que le virage du
numérique on l'avait un peu et on avait
été un peu timorés à la fois en termes
de montants d'investissement et de
timing de temps de réaction ça c'est
vrai sur europe 1 je pense que c'est
aussi un peu vrai sur sur le jdd alors
c'est à la fois sur le produit lui-même
et sur sa distribution
sur le produit lui-même et ça c'est
quelque chose qui avait commencé à faire
hervé gattegno très très brillamment
c'était de commencer à faire des lettres
un peu comme le new york times fait à un
moment dont des lettres qui commence à
être gratuit qui étaient envoyés
ad gratuitement à des gens qui voulaient
bien le les avoirs elles sont devenues
payantes après sur soi l'information
soit la cuisine de choses comme ça on en
a fait une puis deux puis trois et on
s'est aperçu évidemment que ça c'était
un moteur pour nous de faire venir des
abonnés au jdd surtout au moment où on
est passé en payant c'est ce qui
explique en grande partie la réussite de
la stratégie du new york times aux états
unis
en termes de distribution maintenant
alors là franchement c'est un vrai souci
pour nous alors on n'est pas les seuls
le dimanche enfin il n'ya pas ya paria
pas nombre de gens et malheureusement
d'ailleurs on serait plus nombreux
peut-être qu'on serait mieux distribuer
donc évidemment l'idée là dessus c'est
de numériser ce qui est déjà fait le
journal qu'on peut déjà avoir en format
numérique
mais ça prend comment dirais-je du temps
en termes de marketing pour que les gens
sachent comment et où s'abonner mais je
pense que la représentante de la deûle
sdj du du du jdd a eu raison de le dire
elle a eu raison on a été trop timoré en
a probablement fait une petite erreur
sur ce plan là qu'on est en train de
rattraper mais qui nous coûtent
évidemment plus cher maintenant c'est là
où elle a encore doublement raison
concernant le
le travel retail alors on a même plus de
mille 1000 boutiques en france on est le
troisième acteur mondial
derrière du free qui est une entreprise
cotée en suisse qui n'a pas vraiment de
d'actionnaires bien bien précis
et puis bon on peut on peut estimer
qu'on est 2e ou 3e il ya d'autres
acteurs un allemand heinemann
ssp etc
c'est un métier qui est injustement
touché aujourd'hui
mais qui a pu justement permis aux
équipes de réfléchir de faire table rase
de tout ce qui est fait est fait je
avant et de réfléchir au rebond et c'est
là où il faut être le meilleur et le
rebond c'est d'être probablement plus
proche des consommateurs c'est à dire
des touristes des voyageurs et non pas
les saisir si je puis me permettre ce
terme et je m'en excuse au moment où ils
atterrissent mais essayer d'avoir un
contact avec eux avant qu'ils ne
prennent leur vole donc ça peut être des
associations avec des compagnies
aériennes par exemple de leur livrer les
colis au lieu qu'ils aient à attendre
dans les magasins ce que l'on commence à
faire dans leurs hôtels ce qui n'est pas
toujours facile d'ailleurs etc etc donc
ça ça fait partie du du rebond mais on
est tous prêts je peux vous dire qu'on
est tous les acteurs on et prévoyez une
ligne de départ on est tous prêts et on
attend ce rebond et moi je tire profit
de toutes les années que j'ai passées au
sein de eads et d'airbus et j'ai encore
pas mal d'amis qui travaillent et qui me
me donne quelques quelques informations
sur l'éventuelle reprise nous on attend
ça en année pleine en 2023 en année
pleine puisque aujourd'hui on en est pas
encore là les plus pessimistes attend de
ça pour 2024 2025
comme toujours ça arrivera peut-être
entre les deux c'est à dire en 2023 mais
peut-être pas en année pleine
et là ça changera la physionomie la
physionomie du groupe clairement et
c'est un beau métier c'est un très beau
métier alors ça peut-être pas comment
dirais-je le cachet de l'éducation mais
mais mais c'est un très beau métier
quand même est très difficile petit de
commercial extrêmement difficiles dont
je suis optimiste je suis très optimiste
et là vous voyez il n'y a pas de
synergie avec vivendi pourtant ils sont
là avec nous et si on a des acquisitions
affaires qui sont importantes ils seront
là aussi pour nous dernière question du
rapporteur
oui justin justin la dernière question
j'ai regardé par rapport à votre à votre
à votre réponse sur
sur les changements de ligne éditoriale
est ce qu'on a poussé dehors certains et
tous
ont dit que ça coûtait 1 millions
d'euros ça vous a coûté 1 million
d'euros la rupture de contrat et comme
tout et je trouve que ça coûte cher
juste pour le changement de
positionnement comme vous nous l'avez
dit comme seul argument mais j'ai
entendu votre votre réponse et et jean
prat je voulais vous poser avec eux des
questions de peu direct c'est pas vous
pouvez développer si vous voulez ou pas
sur
l'interventionnisme on a posé ces
questions un peu à tous les patrons qui
sont venus devant nous ce qu'il ya des
responsabilités ou actionnaires
vous pouvez nous dire que vous n'êtes
jamais intervenu sur le contenu de
l'information ou sur la volonté qui
viettel contenu ou la volonté qu'il n'y
ait pas tel contenu ton à paris match
car cosider d'aew europe 1 oui je peux
vous le dire alors là en terme de
contenu ou je peux avoir une opinion
c'est sur le positionnement
par exemple la grande question qu'on se
pose tout le temps et là on peut avoir
des divergences avec un rédacteur en
chef c'est
faisons-nous plus de people ou plus
d'informations ce que l'on sait c'est
paris match a failli mourir pour avoir
fait trop d'informations bien avant que
keita qu'ils achètent donc c'était dans
les années 80 et puis après on est passé
à une période où on a fait énormément de
people ça c'était l'oeil très aiguisé de
roger thérond à l'époque donc c'était
c'était le choc des photos davantage que
le poids des mots et puis après on est
arrivés petit à petit un magazine qui
est un espèce d'hybride qui est assez
unique d'ailleurs et c'est pour ça qu'il
marche et qu'il résiste bien et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut préserver donc
à ce titre là j'ai une opinion et à ce
titre là je je peux m'autoriser si je
puis dire à l'imposer bien entendu non
mais ça va sans dire mais ça va mieux en
disant que ce n'est pas de cela dont je
parle et c'est en gros des interventions
je n'aimerais pas qu'on traite ou traite
de telle façon tel sujet ou telle
activité ou tel nom événement etc je
vous dit vous n'êtes jamais intervenu
non ces trois non pas d'évasion le
précise messas essais concernent pas
directement et peut-être que vous êtes
informés
vous pouvez nous dire quelque chose
l'ancien président nicolas sarkozy est
membre du conseil de surveillance oui
lagardère bien sûr et il a intégré
depuis juin 2021 le
il est devenu administrateur
dans la presse
quelque chose est intervenue deux
révélations
de
2,2
d'actes d'information judiciaire qui
dirait qu'il y aurait eu une une
possible intervention ou influence sur
un papier le concernant un interview
notamment dans une affaire le concernant
l esi plus directement parce qu'on s'est
tous de quoi vous parlez
vous le savez puisque vous le savez moi
je vous pose la question est bien sûr
est ce que vous pensez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire qu'il
n'ya pas eu internet mais bien sûr eu
ans mais bien sûr mais bien sûr monsieur
le rapporteur alors je vais jouer par
contre un peu développée ici si vous
voulez bien le choix de monsieur du
président sarkozy au sein de notre de
notre conseil c'est moi qui l'ait fait
et j'en avais besoin j'en avais besoin
parce que comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
il connaît beaucoup de gens dans le
monde et quand on développe par exemple
le travel retail dans certains pays ça
nous est extrêmement utile extrêmement
utile
ensuite il a d'abord il est ce qu'il est
et dans un conseil on a besoin d'eux
d'avoir des personnalités fortes alors
je vais pas me cacher c'est un ami mais
c'est pas une honte non plus et je veux
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas envie de le
cacher il m'a plu aussi comme vincent
bolloré énormément aidés moralement au
décès de mon père et ça c'est des choses
que je n'oublie pas non plus et je suis
très fidèle en amitié vous voyez quand
je dis que j'ai peu d'amis vous en avez
déjà deux je pense avoir encore quelques
uns mais pas beaucoup plus mais ça me
suffit
alors vous parlez donc 2
l'article qui aurait été père à qui a
été fait par un journaliste qui a
d'ailleurs été
interrogé par la police ou je ne sais
trop quoi concernant takieddine il a été
évidemment tout de suite mis hors de
cause lui je crois qu hervé gattegno
aussi a été interrogé et qu'il a été mis
hors de cause bon je n'ai absolument ni
de près ni de loin participé à quoi que
ce soit sur cet article absolument pas
non mais je préfère les choses soient
clairement dit mais vous je n'ai pas des
vhu non mais dis moi pensaient encore
moins lui encore moins lui encore moi je
le sais comme il était maignan cerner et
qu'il est dont le conseil de
surveillance administrateur je vous ai
posé une question oui bien sûr votre
réponse me suffira je n'ai pas moi
absolument de procès ici c'est pour me
former est-ce que vous pensez que dans
cette position et dit pourquoi ford
influence vous avez besoin dans votre
groupe il peut y avoir des sujets et là
c'est poser cette possibilité de de
pouvoir d' influence sur le contenu
journalistique qui peut le conserver
parce qu'étant un un homme public à des
moments il ya quand même des papiers qui
peuvent concerner comme voilà donc c'est
celle envers un peu de jeu combine
avantages que vous avez cherché à avoir
à la voir dans conseil de surveillance
est-ce que la concrètement il aurait pu
avoir une intervention ou une influence
non et le fait qu'il soit au conseil ne
lui donne pas davantage de pouvoir ni un
pouvoir spécifique auprès auprès des
rédactions non
clairement non
merci monsieur lagardère d'âge ont pris
l'eau merci à vous je vous en prie merci
infiniment route et je précise pour mes
collègues que nous auditionneront demain
à 9 heures devant xavier niel dans cette
même salle
voilà il